when you were when you were deployed and
you were all over the place what was the
understanding or or maybe even the
interpretation you had on how different
Iran was dealing with Iran as a
government and Military than some of
these other countries in the Middle East
I mean everyone that I thought in Iraq
was uh Iranian mostly all the
electromagnetic force penetrators were
Iranian and so when you were in Iraq you
really you felt like you were fighting
Iran in a lot of ways all the things
that I studied originated from Iran and
that was my second war the first one was
when I was in uh Beirut and again
Hezbollah was a lot of Iranian influence
so I mean I've spent a lot of my time
dealing with proxy groups from Iran in
Iran's a major player in there and you
know the United States has gone in and
kind of destabilized everyone around
them you know Syria included in that and
now you've got Iran that kind of is just
standing there by itself as the the
regional player what what's their
strength what's their weakness if you
were to say if you you're going to
attack them if you're gonna figure out a
way to help their people revolt against
them where democracy can come there you
would do it this way but this is the one
area their strength you cannot beat them
in this area I think Iran much like
China strength and weaknesses
centralized control and so you can play
that against them but it also can work
to their advantage where the United
States sometimes takes more of a
deliberate group of people coming to a
consensus where a government like Iran
or China can move much quicker because
of the autonomy and centralized control
and so the problem with centralized
control is if you move in a direction
very quickly and it's the wrong
direction now you've actually set
yourself back much further than you
would in like a democratic process so
the the Democratic process is more
resilient because uh you know we have a
lot of voices that need to be heard but
at the same time it doesn't move very
quick and efficiently whereas a
centralized government can and so that's
what that's what I see when I look at
those two places now I ran I don't see
the the Communist Party of China going
anywhere but I don't think the Iranian
the alatola uh kamini I don't see him
lasting very long quite honestly you
know crazier things have happened but
the Iranian people are very proud people
and they're connected technology wise to
the rest of the world and they want to
get you know the Persians of the the day
were probably the the top of the food
chain and they haven't been there in a
long time and so I'd be surprised but
crazier things have happened but I see
Iran going into a revolution in the next
30 Years ish before before the end of my
time I believe in the next 30 year-ish
yeah yeah I'm not saying it'll happen
anytime soon I got you I'm not saying
it'll happen but you can see the you can
see the cracks in the foundation and so
this these this might take a couple
decades but it'll happen so I if I was a
United States President I would do
everything to stay out of my own way
because as I studied that model that
model is destined for implosion on its
own and the worst thing America can do
because oftentimes when you attack a
system you unify the system I mean you
saw in the United States in 911 you can
see it in Iraq like so if you attack the
system you unify the system and so I
would do everything I could not to unify
the Iranian system because that thing's
headed the implosion on its own if your
enemy is making a strategic mistake
don't interrupt them that's right
yeah very interesting in the in the
concept of uh 30 years Iran so China but
on the flip side you said China they're
going to be around for a while I agree
yeah and I think uh yeah China's
continuing to get stronger I've read a
lot of things about how it's all the
shell game and they're going to implode
but I'm not sure I agree with it I think
just the strength of their population
and the you know
some of the shortcuts that they're able
to take right now that we don't take
based on
um a set of morals whether that be right
or wrong
um they're accelerating at a much faster
pace
How how Wild it is that they're they're
becoming allies because China signed a
400 billion dollar 25-year deal with
Iran and for them to unify that some
people say it makes it even tougher for
revolution to happen sooner because they
got the big guys on the other side
defending them backing them up I think
the alliance between Russia Iran and
China is an alliance of weakness so
mostly when you get into an alliance
with someone it's because you see the
world through the same eyes and you
stand for the same principles and values
that's not the case with Iran China and
Russia the reason they are aligned is
because they got no one else to align to
and so when I look at that Alliance are
they all powerhouses in their own right
and does that is that relevant yes but
at the same time you know China doesn't
want to be aligned to Iran they just
don't have anyone else they can align to
do you think it's a sign of weakness I
do I do absolutely do unpack that a
little bit more I think it's like it's
like if I'm on a a base level if I'm on
a playground and one kid gets all the
other kids to follow his lead and so I
try to make friends with like two other
kids that maybe are are not part of the
big group just because that's what's
left I mean China doesn't get to pick
its allies right now right Iran doesn't
get to pick its allies because of just
their behavior and so you know do they
add value by aligning to the other
outcasts sure but to me it's it's
symptomatic of not having a lot of
choices right it's almost like they
don't
they don't have any friends that's right
so it's like that's right you have no
friends you're gonna hang out with the
two other guys that have no friends like
exactly no one else wants to hang out
like you're you're breaking it down to a
playground that's exactly but quite
honestly even then like that might even
hurt you a little bit too because now
you've aligned yourself with Iran right
and we could talk about you know the
injustices of Iran uh for a while same
thing with with Russia so it doesn't
matter you know do they get some
strength and value by you know selling
arms or importing and exporting yes
absolutely they do but
on the long term is it helping them I'm
not convinced talking about you know
Pariah is on the world stage but here's
the question coming together if that's
the case then who who is in your opinion
the number one threat to you is if
you're saying it's a sign of weakness
between Russia China and Iran then who
is US's number one enemy outside of
internal no it is China no doubt no
doubt but I yeah I stand by that their
Alliance isn't it's something based on
what they had available right so is that
a strength of theirs I don't know so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]